-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now we're gonna
get to the news.
President Biden is reportedly
preparing to forgive $10,000
in student-loan debt
for Americans
who make less than $150,000.
$10,000 or, as your college
calls it, a chemistry book.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden traveled today
to Los Angeles.
Not sure what for, but it's got
to have something to do
with "Top Gun."
[ Laughter ]
The public congressional
hearings on the Capitol attack
kick off tomorrow night
in prime time.
And make sure to tune in
afterwards for
"Talking Insurrection,"
hosted by Chris Hardwick.
[ Laughter ]
Fox News announced this week
that it will not carry
live coverage of Congress's
prime-time hearings
over the Capitol attack
to focus on more important news,
like "would it kill Mulan
to wear a dress?"
[ Laughter ]
British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson on Monday narrowly
survived a no-confidence vote
in Parliament.
And from the looks of him,
he also narrowly survived
electrocution.
[ Laughter ]
[ English accent ] "I think
the hair looks quite good.
I think I'll go out now
and let everyone know
that I have confidence.
I have confidence
that the hair is good."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] According to
a new poll, 72% of New Yorkers
believe Mayor Eric Adams is
doing better than or as well as
his predecessor, Bill de Blasio.
I knew, if we just gave him
a chance, he would prove just
how much we didn't like
Bill de Blasio.
[ Laughter ]
The CDC this week raised its
monkeypox alert to level two.
Though if you want people
to take it seriously,
don't change the alert level.
Change the name.
"Monkeypox" just sounds
too cute.
"Monkeypox!
Oh, you guys, should we get it?"
[ Laughter ]
"I'm gonna get it
for the summer."
[ Laughter ]
A man in California was arrested
this week for allegedly stealing
an Olympic gold medal
from a car.
Officials suspected the man
was guilty
when they very easily caught up
to him.
[ Laughter ]
Singer Jimmy Buffett's
new Margaritaville at Sea
cruise line recently launched
its first ship
for a one-night-only
inaugural voyage.
And nothing says "safety"
like "Margaritaville,"
a song that is about a drunk guy
who cuts himself
and decides to get drunker.
[ Laughter ]
There are some people on this
show who are of the age
that we know the plotlines of
the Jimmy Buffett songs.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, at a recent press
conference, a judge in India
referenced a case where a man
filed for divorce from his wife
because she cooked him
instant noodles for every meal.
Well, fortunately for that guy,
he's already got a solid idea
of what single life
is gonna be like.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody!